welcome everyone
thank you for joining us for our
presentation titled update
on screening for hepatocellular
carcinoma hcc
it's my pleasure to introduce you to dr
khaldoon almhana
associate professor of medicine the
warren alpert medical school of brown
university
lifespan cancer institute
gastrointestinal oncology
rhode island hospital after earning his
medical degree from damascus university
in damascus syria dr amhanna received
his master in public health degree
at the case western reserve university
in cleveland ohio
his research has involved clinical and
translational investigations
in gastrointestinal tumors currently he
is an associate professor at the warren
albert medical school of brown
university
and working at the lifespan cancer
institute with several talented
oncologists
to help strengthen the gastrointestinal
research portfolio
in the gi oncology department he has
been the lead investigator
on several multi-central trials and
developed his own investigator initiated
treatment
for a complete biography on our speaker
please visit the tab
at the top of your screen if any
questions arise during the presentation
we encourage you to submit them in the q
a box our speaker will address your
questions
following the presentation please join
me in welcoming
dr khaldoon omhana i will now turn the
presentation
over to him
thank you alexis for the introduction
hello everybody and
good morning good evening good afternoon
depending where you are in the world
today i'll be presenting an update on
screening for hepatocellular
carcinoma for a full disclosure i am
presenting on behalf of abbott
and the information i'm presenting are
based on
my interpretation of the evidence and
clinical
expertise
as you all know hepatocellular carcinoma
is a primary liver malignancy that's
typically developed in the setting of
chronic liver disease
and cirrhosis primary liver cancer is
common and it's the fourth
fourth leading cause of cancer-related
mortality worldwide with over 780
000 reported deaths back in 2018.
the five-year survival is still dismal
and it's only 18
the diagnosis of hcc can be difficult
and often requires
the use of one or more imaging
modalities
and htc is frequently
diagnosed late in its course because of
the absence of symptoms
and the reluctant of primary care
physician to provide surveillance for
their high
risk population ideally we would like to
diagnose tumor when
they are less than centimeter in size so
all treatment options can be offered
including surgery
local therapy as well as transplantation
although for many patients the diagnosis
of hcc can be made with
imaging alone biopsy may be required in
patients who lack
history of cirrhosis or other chronic
disease
or for those with suspicious but
non-specific finding
on imaging hepatocellular carcinoma is
known
to be different between different
geographic locations looking at this map
you notice the increased uptake sorry
the increase
incidence and prevalence in certain
areas of the world including
southwest china and west africa
in the united states the incidence is
around or the prevalence is 1.8 to 2.4
per 100 000 population
looking at the pathology we have a liver
injury
from nash or hepatitis that lead to
chronic liver disease
which leads to liver cirrhosis and leads
to hepatocellular carcinoma
looking at this slide we know that
notice that there are several
opportunities of screening
so we can intervene before the patient
move
through those three stages
most commonly is between liver cirrhosis
and hepatocellular carcinoma
and hopefully in the future between
chronic liver disease and liver
cirrhosis as well
we will talk in more details about
surveillance in the next several slides
the goal of surveillance as i said is to
collect
hcc at an early stage when it's less
than two centimeter in size
which has a favorable effect on outcome
the data
unfortunately on surveillance and
surveillance benefit has been very
conflicting
historically an old randomized trial for
screening for hcc in patient with
hepatitis b
showed that surveillance for high-risk
patient can lead to 37
reduction in mortality in patients with
hepatitis b infection
another subsequent meta-analysis showed
similar result where hcc surveillance
was associated with significant
improvement
in early tumor detection of course
leading to receipt of corrective
curative therapy and overall survival in
patient with cirrhosis
more subsequent and recent analysis
failed to show any significant evidence
that the effect of hcc screening on
mortality
in patients with chronic liver sorry
that
screening can have a positive effect on
hcc
mortality in patients with chronic liver
disease
so how do we go about surveillance we
one of the easiest and simplest and
cheapest tests is
ultrasound it is a highly specific test
with 90 percent specificity however it
has low sensitivity
in a meta-analysis the sensitivity can
be as
low as 63 in early stage disease
ultrasound has a lot of limitation it is
very operator dependent
based on the radiologist's experience
patient dependent depend on their liver
their body habitus and obviously it
failed to detect infiltrative disease
there is a lot of talk about including
ct scan and mri for screening for hcc
however
that has not been established and it's
it will be very
costly
serum alpha phytoprotein another
screening tool
is serum alpha fetal protein which is
the most commonly used
marker for hcc alpha fetal protein is a
glycoprotein which is normally produced
during gestation by fetal liver
and the old sac sensitivity and
specificity
defer and depends on what cutoff is used
and the incidence and prevalence of
disease like every other screening test
elevated serum alfa fetoprotein is
non-specific and can be elevated with
patients
in patients with chronic liver disease
with or without hcc
and also could be associated with the
presence of fibrosis only
alpha fetal protein can be elevated as
well in pregnancy
and in other malignancies like
testicular cancer
and gastric cancer
this is a table
showing several studies that look at
sensitivity and specificity
of alpha phytoprotein in detecting
patients of hcc
obviously the difference
with between this study is the cutoff
that has been used because it's between
20 nanogram to 200 nanogram
and of course a different number of
cases
based on this we see that the
sensitivity is all over the place and it
goes from 25
to 65 percent the specificity
is between 80 to 90 percent
this is again in close sectional studies
if we look at another table where we're
looking at alpha fetal protein on
prospective cohort studies
again we have the same problem we have
sensitivity that is law
ranging between 39 to 65 percent
and a specificity between high 70 to 90
percent
and again it's all depend on the number
of patient that have been tested and
followed
in general it is accepted that if alpha
photoprotein value is more than
400 nanogram per ml in the right setting
meaning in a patient
in the highest patient with liver
disease or with cirrhosis
alpha phytoprotein more than 400 is
diagnostic of hcc with a specificity as
high as 95 percent
and fortunately fewer than fifth hcc
cases are associated with such high
level of alpha fetal protein
given the problems that we saw with
sensitivity and specificity
alpha topin has been removed from
certain society guidelines
including organ transplantation
network and united network of organ
sharing
as a diagnostic test for hcc
now we'll move on to another marker
which the prothrombin induced by vitamin
k absence to
pivka it's also sometimes referred to as
protein induced by vitamin k
absence to pepka or dcp
this gamma carboxyl
carboxy protrumping
what is vivka normal hepatocytes usually
carboxylate protrompin
precursor before secreting it into the
blood which is usually dependent on
vitamin k
in patients with hcc
this does not happen and pivka2
which is the precursor of protrom penis
means is
being secreted to the circulation in a
non-carboxylated
form or an immature form which called
pivka
pivka2 is increased in the serum of hcc
patient
and it has been recognized not only as a
highly specific marker
but also a predictor of prognosis of hcc
according to more recent systemic
reviews perfect ii showed better
diagnostic performance than alpha
phytoprotein for the diagnosis of early
hcc looking at several studies that look
again we're looking at alpha fetal
protein at a different kind of level
different number of patients we looked
at
alpha phetoprotein sensitivity is
comparing to pivka sensitivity
and we see that carry a higher
specificity
and in certain cases a higher
sensitivity but again these
were not compared head to head
another marker is alpha fetal protein l3
alpha fetal protein l3 is a fecal
selected isoform alpha phetoprotein
where the sugar chain structure of alpha
fetal protein obtained from patients
with liver cirrhosis and hcc have
different
affinities to lectins
alpha fetal protein in several series
have shown to be elevated in patient
with hcc
and can be detected early and the
percentage
of alpha fetal protein l3 is highly
specific for hcc
obviously none of the markers that were
presented is a home run
all of them have problems based on the
cutoff
and based on the incidence and
prevalence of disease
and they have a low sensitivity and
specificity
that's why some studies start looking
at combining these markers
so in this analysis we see
that alpha fetal protein alone using the
cutoff of 20 nanogram per ml
showed the sensitivity of only 60 and
specificity of 71 percent
with again low positive protective value
and 88
negative predictive value when we look
at alpha fetal protein 3
percent alone again have the same
problem with low sensitivity high
specificity
and high negativity value but low pass
deposited value
and the same applied to dcp or pivka
when we start adding and using combining
actually those markers we see that the
sensitivity slightly start improving
when we add two markers alpha
photoprotein plus alpha photoprotein l3
alpha fetoprotein plus pivka
and when we add the three together the
sensitivity improves significantly
between 60 to 77 percent
the specificity actually go lower
however negative predictive value
also go up that past the predicted value
go down
this all trigger
possibility of combining these
in models to have a better sensitivity
and specificity for a test
that can lead to change outcome in
patient with hcc
for the next several slides i'm going to
go through the current recommendation
depend on your geographic location
so screening of hcc based on the
american association for the study of
liver disease the asld
currently they represent ultrasound with
or without alpha fetal protein
every six months alpha fetal protein
alone should not be used for screening
unless it is done with ultrasound
and the screening again occur between
four to eight months approximately six
months
as the median time for hcc region to
grow is 117 days ranging from
29 to 398 days
asld does not suggest performing
surveillance in patients with a very
advanced disease where treatment
options are limited unless the patient
is listed
for transplant
for the asian pacific association for
the study of the liver they have similar
screening guideline they recommend
combination of ultrasound and
amphiphetoprotein measurement every six
months
they use a very high cutoff of alpha
fetal protein of 200 nanogram per ml
for patients with cirrhosis and they
don't suggest screening again to
serratic patients who are not eligible
for treatment or not on transplant lists
for the japanese society of hepatology
their recommendations for screening are
different
because beside alpha phetoprotein of
ultrasound they recommend epika2 and
alpha phetoprotein 3 they
divide the patient into two group
patients with high-risk disease
and patient with extremely harsh disease
for the patient with high risk disease
they recommend screening with ultrasound
along with these three tumor markers
every six months
for patients with extremely high disease
they provide doing it more often
every three to four months
so let's give you an idea of where we
are
on the screening for htc in patients who
are a high risk
unfortunately the data are all over the
place
and we have a lot of unmet needs
number one the incidence is increasing
number two the underlying liver disease
leading to hcc
have changed so the landscape of
screening should change as well we used
to screen patient with hepatitis b
now we are we have to start thinking
about vision of the pediatrician and
nash and other type of cirrhosis
we'd have a problem with the lack of
highly sensitive and specific tests
this based on some of the data on the
combination led to creating
models that incorporate biomarkers
with other clinical aspects of
the disease to help predict
incidence or progression of psoriatic
patient to hcc
the first model that i'll talk about is
the galad model
which stands for or it incorporates
gender
age and three serological marker
including alpha fetal protein l3 alpha
fetal protein
and dcp or pivka2
in biomarker study gallup has shown to
be
promising for predicting
uh hcc at an early stage it's really a
mathematic model that
incorporates all these variables
including as i said
the gender the age and the serum markers
in recent study that when combined with
ultrasound
it can help provide more accurate
information for clinician
to treat or do more imaging for patient
at an early stage
in march 2020 fda granted a breakthrough
device designation
for the gallup score
when we look at the rock curve
for gallaudet in comparison to
single tumor marker including alpha
fetal protein
protein iii and dcp we see
that the gallon outperform
each individual markers and those are
two series from
uk and japan
in a trial where they look at galat
following reception they had 326
patients with hcc undergoing reception
percent 195 patients recur
while 131 didn't when
after a section the gallup score had
declined in all patients however
the decline was most marked in patients
that
had no recurrence by three years which
led
to believe that maybe serial measurement
of gallup
may permit early detection of recurrence
how this data is going to be used
prospectively
is yet to be seen
another model is the moral model the
moral model is model of recurrence after
liver transplant
currently liver transplant follows say
the milan criteria are used to allocate
liver
to patient with hcc and it only depend
on the disease the size of the disease
and the patient characteristics they
don't
incorporate tumor biology
and this is what this model is trying to
do is looking at alpha fetal protein
at pivka in this simple calculation to
see if that
predict the recurrence free survival and
overall survival in patient undergoing
transplant
it is simple it's highly accurate tool
for predicting recurrence and risk
stratification pre
and post-operatively again further
studies are needed for this model as
well
for it to be validated for future use
the next model is the asap asap model or
sap
asap stands for age sex alpha
phetoprotein and pivka2
this is another model that includes
those four variable
it was tested recently in a multi-center
trial for patient with hcc
secondary to hbv in asia it's an
online free use calculator
based on the most recent study
sensitivity was as high as 76 percent
and specificity was 90 percent in
detecting
early stage hcc or detecting hcc
this is how the model look like so you
are
giving point based on sex age
alpha fetal protein and pivka2 and then
you calculate the total mine at total
points
and that total point will predict your
risk
for example a patient who is 28 year old
with alpha fetal protein of 3.1 and 5k
value of 19
his risk is very low at 4.3
percent or probability of hcc risk and
this number can be used to decide on
what type of further
uh workup or how often he needs more
imaging or more testing
obviously if looking here when the alpha
fetal protein is higher and the
value is higher we are at risk of 44
and in this case the current risk
of developing cc is high and the patient
would require immediate
further imaging including triple phase
ct or an mri
or further evaluation obviously if the
numbers
are much higher like in this panel and
the
estimated risk is or probability of 54
percent this patient need also
further imaging and evaluation because
he is at a higher risk
of already developing hcc
the two gallon versus asap in general
the variable overlapped in both they are
using
similar or similar or the same variable
other than alpha protein 3
it was not part of the asap model
because it was insignificant
in predicting hcc in multivariate model
multivariable model
that uh limited use in hepatitis b in
particular
gallup has not been yet validated in
patient with hpv
there was a retrospective comparison
that showed that asap
normogram be better predictive of hcc
however everything has limitation these
are all small study
there is a lot of selection bias giving
the design of the study
patient with hcc even with the asap were
diagnosed at more
advanced stage some patients who did not
have hcc still had
elevated alpha phytoprotein and 5k2
leading to a high
risk calculation longer follow-up and
specific study
in patients with elevated pivka3 are
still needed
and of course anything need external
validation especially studies that
compare
that test to the standard of care
which is currently ultrasound and alpha
fetal protein these study are also
needed
again the data based on the most current
study are based on a single assay
and it was for patient with hbv so
validation in non-hpv patients is still
needed
in conclusion hcc is a common and
increasing malignancy
it is rapidly rising cause of liver
related death in the united states and
in the world
screening and surveillance for liver
cancer could save life
with early detection where patients have
several treatment and putative options
multiple societies still recommend hcc
screening
in high-risk patients
with all the data i presented i think
it's important to understand the
strength
the weakness and the limitation of the
available screening methods
is important all these new combination
of tests and normogram
are showing promising results however it
need to be validated more in future
prospective studies
and integrating this biomarker in hcc
treatment pathway as a surrogate for
treatment response
or disease recurrence which is important
to us as oncologists
or to surgeon is extremely important
this will end my presentation thank you
very much and i'll be happy to take any
questions
thank you dr amhanna for that
outstanding presentation
we will now move into the live q a
portion of the presentation
as a reminder please submit your
questions via the q a box
our first question is do you see these
models or markers
incorporated in transplant criteria and
organs allocations
as i said the current transplant
criteria include
patients and tumor characteristics so
it's tumor size
patients characteristic including
alcohol use
uh compliance psych issues and
infections
it would be nice to incorporate these
criteria but
it needs to be really validated
prospectively before
it is used as
a criteria for transplant or allocation
of organs
now are any of these tests currently
being evaluated in patients following
liver transplant
surgical resection as a predictive for
disease recurrence
so i mentioned that the galad model has
been
used or looked at as a predictive of
recurrence following
resection and following uh transplant
however
really how that affects uh
treatment algorithm or frequency of
imaging
is yet to be determined because if we're
going to depend only on the numbers
we're going to
order more tests to increase incl cause
more anxiety
and unnecessary testing
without really changing the outcome so
again this need to be validated
prospectively before
we incorporate it and of course it has
to
we have to make sure that it will
affect the overall outcome and survival
now dr alhana with the chambers in the
landscape of treating metastatic hcc
do you see a role of using these models
in treatment selections or
monitoring response
so currently all the drugs that are
approved for hcc
don't have any predictive marker for
response
uh tumor markers especially a fetal
protein
is used as a surrogate for response to
treatment
however numbers are numbers and they
should really be used as surrogate not
as
only predictive of response
we still are going to depend on scanning
and imaging and clinical pictures
however if we have something that's very
sensitive and specific
it will sure be helping guiding uh
following response to treatment not
choosing the treatment
and it looks like we have time for one
more question is there any role
of incorporating cdna in any of these
models
so circulating dna is currently being
used or tested in several malignancy it
has gone further in certain magnets than
others
in hcc it has not been established as a
predictive or a prognostic model
uh and it hasn't been part of the
standard of care obviously
we would like to have more data and
incorporating circulating dna
with these markers to predict uh
response
or risk of recurrence and again these
are all
very immature and still early in
development
thank you again dr omaha and thank you
to the audience for your outstanding
questions
we hope you found today's presentation
to be informative and insightful
this presentation will be available for
on-demand viewing
don't miss out on the other valuable
presentations on our agenda visit the
agenda tab in the auditorium full
for a full listing thank you again for
your participation
and until next time goodbye